hey parents we know that trying to help
your kids with their essays can often
feel like navigating through an unknown
City without a map but don't worry we're
here to provide the compass that you
need we're proud to present our latest
kigo feature academic essay feedback
this new feature provides immediate
highquality feedback on essays helping
your child become a more confident
writer let me show you how it works to
get started all your child needs to do
is submit a draft essay from any class
be it English US Government history Etc
click submit then kigo gets to
work right now kigo works best for
persuasive argumentative explanatory or
literary analysis essays up to about
1500 words you can see that kigo offers
insights into everything from essay
structure and organization to how well
arguments are supported even down to
style and tone your child can view the
feedback ask for
clarifications
make
revisions and then request more
review it's like having a personal
writing coach at your
fingertips and unlike other AI tools
such as chat GPT kigo doesn't do the
writing for your child it also goes
beyond just correcting grammar or
spelling instead it's like a trusted
Mentor that guides students through the
entire revision process and you can get
unlimited access to this feature and
everything else kigo has to offer for
just $4 a month or $44 a year click the
link in the description below to learn
more and get started with
Kiko